I'm calling to confirm that I've received your order by fax.
However, we need to discuss the payment schedule for your order.
Can I get back to you about this?
I don't usually deal with payments and the person who usually handles them is out to lunch.
I see. Would you like me to explain the payment options to that person?
I think we talked about that when we met here in my office.
I think you can leave it to me to inform her of the payment options.
When you have decided on the option you'd like to use, please call me back.
I'll do that.
Is there anything else we need to discuss regarding our order?
No. Once we organize the payment schedule, everything will be set.